[Music]
excuse me
she's been like crying for hours sorry
but this is a group for new
mothers on that sign out there it says
parents i'm a parent and i don't know
what the hell i'm doing
girl's got some stuff flying out of ass
she can either hit you with a streamer
or she'll buckshot you
it's a quick whop i need help
i don't know how you're going to do this
if you've had only one parent i wish you
could've had your mom
because she would have been better right
and mommy was the best
man go to sleep go to sleep
he's not working
matthew darling we think you should move
back to minnesota you're all alone here
she needs family raising a child it's a
non-stop all day all night of faith
i look you look great i'm sad just to be
saying that you look
like a king king of the slain does it
look
i think it's a new look i think it's a
new hairstyle that can catch on if given
a chance
mr lovely madeline doesn't have a mother
to model after i am well aware
of what my daughter doesn't have you
think you can do this but you can't no
man you're right i can't do it but you
know what
i'm going to do it because i'm a father
[Music]
god maddie you thank god the day i got
there in time
she was gone and you it's always just
us other people have more people around
you i just want to do what your mom
would have wanted me to do i
promised them trying to make everything
perfect
but we don't have any control wherever
you are
i want to go there wherever you are i
want to go there too
somebody's cutting onions or something
close to us or something i don't know
hey y'all gotta stop it oh
she'd be so proud of you
[Music]
don't be scared
[Music]
you